hi reject nation I'm Greg album Oh Cass
over here alright let's up guys Greg
Alva here what up amy castle you can
follow her on instagram it's Amy castle
I follow her God follows her you should
follow her to both of them Amy yes it's
amazing me me me me I was called the
amazing Amy as a kid that's a good one
that's a good one
true I was called gay Greg as a kid like
animals I like this got sent to me it's
just from another channel who I saw a
compilation from and I don't really
watch compilations that much anymore
okay coming who doesn't watch those
compilations on our when you're saying I
don't judge you I'm like why would you
judge me about your the animal oh
transitioning back now I just look like
a pervert I felt like oh you're making a
second okay whatever look we're gonna
watch this video from oh good channel
called top 50 savage animals and his
compilations I've noticed live up to the
titles well that has to be Castle
approved let's watch them get seven
what's that gorilla doing play
[Music]
[Laughter]
that was so staged I hope so it was oh
look at the cows oh oh boy that cow is
like why are you being so fierce with me
Oh yo yo back off my [ __ ] it's like get
on my watch you what she wants you want
you I didn't need the edited sound
effects but alright
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
got this shot this is before drones got
a killer shot
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
y'all better back the [ __ ] up my god
[Music]
it's like watching a Planet of the Apes
movie yup like a joint yeah he does a
tough day to be a champ and I live for
about one cigarette a day
[Music]
that's really good I like it
oh those up she's coming out
it's like that was not a good sound
effect their great side effect oh he
just was so gentle that a category just
landed yeah water
oh I've seen this one
Wow good timing Oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
I want to leave that's one my dogs we
got a hot car the way you ran oh my god
Wow so mean this Mary fly so get it
anyway whoa
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
Wow you got that camera
[Music]
okay okay watch episode pair like oh
he's oh my gosh so smart oh my god lever
I love it
[Music]
that was excellent
very good Wow wow that was really
delightful man so entertaining that was
really delight you know what I like more
than animals animals with sound effects
yeah I learned somebody's animals seem
so dangerous like I was wondering why
some of those people were right next to
those elephants for so much of it to get
that video video I go to Africa
get viral video die that one that
elephant was attacking the fans and then
the other three came out that's a
terrifying a situation of being that's
so much power was definitely a
commercial he just bloated oh that was
totally a commercial I loved the one
where the guy just has a brand-new dog
so I do cleaning myself again he seemed
surprised a dog oh my god these are
beautiful animals my favorite ones are
when they're in the zoo and they fight
back because there's make me sad exactly
to be wherever they're happy like that
one elephant in what Thailand or
whatever yeah hates oh yeah that's a
great video I love that video so much I
do all the animals to be able to pursue
their artistic abilities that elephant
moved to LA it would have such a career
[Music]
hey emmi job on that one
[Music]
I love the monkeys that are thieves I
love the ones I want to break out of the
zoo what the chimp a chimp with the
smoking of the cigarette there it looked
like that's his routine got me beat Oh
makes the time fly by smoking my
cigarette no he really smoked like it
was a joint here oh he did animals yes
you know me Greg Alva I know you a
castle yes do the crab battle is
terrifying
he already has terrifying fingers I love
crustaceans Castle you know she loves
crustaceans with weapons that's
something you can guarantee about her
you know it's a complimentary color the
knife it's blue he's like sure that's
the same voice I get out of that y'all
better get out of here you hear me
you're doing an improv class right
showing us a variety of accents the way
[Laughter]
well that was another great video video
great compilation you did not disappoint
topped engine whoever you are whoever
you guys are I don't leave like it or
women were hashtag me too you can
subscribe to the a me castle follower
it's a me castle ladies and gentlemen
also check us on patreon full-length TV
show reactions a weekly Q&A is music
video coverage would love to have you
become a patron Jack today is a short
film and we did sketch Twitter and check
it out get it click notification bells a
lot of instructions at the end of a
video hope you enjoyed